how's it going everybody
so some recently leaked concept art for
Avengers four came out a few days ago
and there was a mysterious weapon in one
of the photos that nobody really knew
what it was there are a lot of guesses
out there and as you can see it looks
kind of Asgardian
some people thought that it could
possibly be a second Stormbreaker
somehow and some people such as myself
thought that this could possibly be
black dwarfs original weapon but there
is a new theory out there that kind of
combines the two theories could this
possibly be an Asgardian weapon and can
black dwarf have wielded the weapon at
one point depending on how you take this
theory both are possible also my
giveaway still continues if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
or Ant Man and the wasp your choice a
special edition poster and some special
collector's items all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero so this weapon
looks a lot like the one that black
dwarf is holding in this photo they're
almost identical except for the handle
but if you look at the handle it looks
exactly like mule nears so both of these
things that I just mentioned are a part
of this theory and to really talk about
this theory we have to talk about the
fear itself saga and the fear itself
saga The Avengers were facing the
serpent the serpent was pretty much
kicking their butts so the Avengers
actually go to Asgard and Tony Stark
pleads with Odin to allow him to use yo
metal guru metal is the same metal that
mule NER is made out of and Stormbreaker
which we saw in Avengers infinity war
Odin allows the Avengers to use uber
metal and eight newly forged weapons are
combined with earu metal and Tony
Stark's repulsor technology and are
thrown into a vat of boiling
earu tony stark himself jumps in with
his armor on and he comes out along with
the weapons now coated in yo metal the
weapons are now very enhanced and a lot
stronger than they were before and
they're distributed to the Avengers and
if you take a look at this photo right
here miss Marvel's weapon looks a lot
like this axe so we could possibly see
this happen in Avengers 4 I've actually
done a video on this before talking
about Iron Man's new armor the iron
destroyer because the Avengers now know
that Thor's hammer Stormbreaker was
stronger than the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet so it only makes sense that the
Avengers would say hey Thor can we go to
that dine Starnet oval ear and get some
weapons ourselves so that's how this
weapon could be Asgardian and again the
handle looks exact
like Mule nears handle and we know that
Captain Marvel will be joining the
Avengers in the fight against Thanos and
Avengers sport so it would make sense
that she would get a weapon as well as
far as black dwarf is concerned we know
that Captain Marvel takes place in the
past before the events of the Avengers
age of Ultron infinity war all of those
and we know that in the comics Captain
Marvel is capable of surviving in space
so maybe at one point in time she goes
to Asgard
and gets this weapon from Odin I say
that because this weapon clearly looks
Asgardian and thanks to an easter egg in
Avengers infinity war it is highly
speculated that black dwarf and Captain
Marvel fight at some point in time as
you can see here in the scene it looks
like black dwarf is wearing a part of
Captain Marvel's uniform maybe as some
sort of a trophy for defeating her so
that's how black dwarf could have
possibly gotten his hands on this weapon
so that is the new theory that this
mysterious weapon in this concept art is
actually going to be captain Marvel's
weapon I personally would love to see
some sort of scene related to this fear
itself' scene and again I think it only
makes sense for the Avengers to get more
irritants but let me know what you all
think hit me with your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like this video so
you can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date with everything related to Avengers
4 as always thank you so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]